way so here is the here i am
back again uh my name is darius i'm
gonna talk about
uh the gamers of the week which is next
topic today and uh for today i prepared
few games from the
opera rapid from the champions chess
tour
that you know happened over the course
of the last few days
and i think that you know in general
those
online tournaments there are lots of
let's say interesting games being played
and um especially with uh
i don't know with such players like for
instance daniel duboff who
are you know very very creative and with
great
preparation and
huge resourcefulness the games are even
more interesting
so indeed i prepared some two of his
games actually
i'm not sure we could cover one in too
big of a detail because
all of them prepared are pretty
interesting um
they're short but none of that
nonetheless uh lots of things happen in
them
so the first one i prepared for today is
uh
daniel double versus ding liran
the game that lasted like just up just
two oh
sorry i didn't mean to click that only
18 moves
daniel managed to bid to
win against
[Music]
against a chinese number one player
in only 18 moves which is a
pretty much unique uh
unique uh situation because uh
also the ingredient is known for its
very solid style and to being
in 18 moves no matter the time control
it's
a i guess a huge achievement and
especially for spectators uh it's it's a
very
fun to watch you know such decisive
games okay so what happened the four
knight f6 knight f3 d5
c4 e6 g3 daily was well known for his uh
a catalan and here he employed one of
the
newest ideas in catalan bishop before
knight pd2
this move of course the novelty is one
let's say three possible lines here
uh i always consider this move as
slightly
uh inferior to relative to 55 bishop d2
we and personally i've only played
myself bishop d2 in this position
however 92 leads to uh very sharp
often leads to very sharp positions
which are pretty much
in do in the both style i would say
and especially you know good preparation
you can catch
your opponent there so definitely there
is
some lots of room to explore um because
of possibilities here for white
to look for an advantage or at least
some practical chances
so uh knight bd2 d takes c4 uh bishop g2
and now uh as far as i know the main
move here is b5
and i think b5 is uh comfortably
equalizing as far as i know
um i would be really curious what
daniel lubovo prepared against b5 uh
there are some crazy lines like
um i remember alexi pato once played
after a4 c6 short castle showcase move
like knight e1 or something like this
sometimes he played also uh cbcb knight
g5 or something like this
stuff like that he played i i know and
after knight d5 e4 if i'm not mistaken
and
this positions are extremely extremely
sharp and um
perhaps i would say uh that was looking
for some
ideas here but of course it's only
my uh guess
[Music]
i don't know it will be interesting
definitely to see what he had in mind
after move b5 which i think is the
best move here in on uh the english ram
play move a5 which is like it's also
impossible
uh a free bishop takes d2 billion takes
d2
uh short castle and queen c2 but with
this move order we actually transpose to
different position
which is well known to be
quite dangerous for black in my opinion
because if black plays not uh
after bishop g2 i will come back here
for a second if black play is not
b5 or a5 but let's say short castle then
queen c2
a5 is actually a line and i know right
now a3 bishop takes d2 bishop takes the
2 b5 is a modern concept of how to
approach this position
a4 c6 and this is exactly what happened
later in the game
but from different move order so in the
in the game fold
coming back from this initial position
a5 a3 bishop takes d2 bishop takes d2
short castle queen c2 b5 norm is
logical to defend this uh c4 pawn a4 and
c6
in this position i analyzed it i
remember in 2017 i think
uh or 18 17 or 18.
i don't remember so one of those years
and i
remember that i think uh i think 17
still but anyway it doesn't matter
uh what uh i analyzed here is that uh
i thought that this position is pretty
much uh you know totally okay for blood
for
for black and my key idea here
was that of course even the most logical
the only move that i considered back in
the day
was move e4 and then my uh
refutation of this idea of course if
black white gets to play with e5 for
example let's say some random like
bishop b7
then e5 knight g5 would be extremely
dangerous because
first of all this knight comes towards
the king side and
you know there's uh queen h is made in
one fret so
and if g6 then all the dark squares are
weak around the
white king i'm sorry black king slide e4
would be
for instance very very unpleasant to me
as well
uh of course there are possibly other
possible possibilities but
this looks very very annoying to black
that's why i
this was the the move only i analyzed
back in the day
but here uh black and play move e5 and
this was the game
of tomaszewski versus doing lyran black
returns the pawn
um in order to stop that position in the
center
and obtain some squares for for the
knights and the game
i if i remember correctly the this game
was pretty much
solving this line in my analysis so
let's just see what happens it takes e5
knight d7
which should be free because right now
an ic5 could be an idea let's see 593
could be an idea
so bishop is logical but uh right now we
renewed this idea with knight a6
and also when playing with knight b4 so
that's why i thought that this is
a very clean way of you know solving
this uh problem
solving you know or equalizing in this
in this line
a shortcut let's say knight c5 knight
okay 93 not not now
but soonish rook v8 of course version is
still very very complicated and i'm not
saying that this is
uh absolutely you know um
okay for black but according to my
analysis this was you know
pretty decent and here
[Music]
actually he didn't play never knight d3
but you know because of the game of the
course of the game
but uh he just caught a perpetual here
with uh knight a2 and queen c3 like
before queen uh sorry
a then before queen c32 queen c2
and uh yeah so i thought that this is
basically the refutation of this line or
like you know another
solution to this to his line fc6 and i
wanted to play this with black but then
modern theory basically uh
lc or alpha zero and everything just
developed
new completely new paths which all and
which have common denominator which is
basically playing without castle
and immediately rushing
to to basically check my opponent
uh with some attack so and those attacks
involve moves like h4 and this is
exactly what happened in this game
and this is not a novelty there have
been a few games already like this
but uh white score in i think 90
in this uh like in this in this line
i think only one there was one draw i
don't
who play with white no remember but with
black played way e
uh and he played move knight a6 i think
but which is also kind of like weird
because knight e5
becomes really really annoying on this
diagonal on pawns he's
hanging and you know polishing some
things nearly lost for black
so this is also also wrong so um
after h4 um well in general let's ask
ourselves what's happening why
h4 what's the idea of h4 um because
you know the is there really such a
dangerous attack on the king side or
what's going on like is it's really so
bad um
i would say yes uh it's become
maybe not bad but i would say it is
definitely dangerous for black
why because there is no dark square
bishop and with
what darks were bishop all the dark
squares are weak and
also potentially the king will be weak
on the on the king's side without desert
start with bishop
and this idea of h4 basically usually
i'll just just give a perspective
usually white goes for some
stuff like let's say b3 or something c b
queen takes b3
you know before let's say maybe rook c1
or 81
fd1 or ac1 you know typical
catalan compensation this is possible
but um
oh sorry i i didn't mean to click that
this is you know let's say typical what
uh
black usually goes for here
[Music]
however sorry white goes for here
but this is kind of like slow this
approach of
castle uh you know bishop b7 b3 and
someone's kind of slow
we are not creating any danger towards
black king
and we try to play position on the queen
side
which is um less optimal i would say no
it's not not optimal h4 is a modern
approach
which mainly creates some first words
against black king
um 97
it happened in the game and this 97 move
apart is actually
seem okay it's logical right isn't it
uh but what can i say it's nearly losing
pretty much pretty much nearly losing
move
and after 97
the point is that suddenly there are
some certain problems on this diagonal
and well what should have been played
here is with bishop b7
to make sure that this diagonal is well
covered and paul says the c6 pawn is
uh well defended as well after bishop b7
let's say h5
h6 analyze here and right now uh
this would enjoy what black should do
here so i try to analyze it a little bit
and i want to share my analysis with you
what should white do here and um
you know castling you know shorts the
castle
king side pretty much makes absolutely
no sense because we already played h4h5
so we would kind of declare there's
something we want to do on the king side
uh so castling shorts casting kingside
makes no sense
playing b3 also makes no sense so the
only way
pretty much to continue here is to
somehow create an attack on the king
side and the way to do it is
very very straightforward g4 uh
the only way pretty much to continue
let's say the initiative here
and i'm not saying that this is uh
winning or something perhaps black can
you know equalize
uh with correct play but position
becomes extremely dangerous
unless you're united g4 and simply rook
g1 and it doesn't matter we sacrifice
another pawn
and our king is our king our own king is
in the center
we open the king side to immediately
create a threat against black king we do
not care about
our king is in the center actually our
king
is very very safe so it makes no sense
uh
to castle it to you know queens our king
side
is perfectly sound and save on the kings
in the center
and instead we just focus on developing
the attack on the in the
um on the king side
so analyze f5 bishop h3 that's the
entire idea to basically change the
knight on
g4 open g file and go for some mating
attack
and uh in general in such situations
whenever
what because white side white is pretty
much a create
attacking on the king side right so in
whites one side
attacks on the side of the board the
defending side should generally
not try to defend on the same side of
the board instead
the other defending side should open the
center in order to
look for counter play rather than
passively defending
and that's exactly very nice example of
this uh
say principle of like a rule of thumb or
whatever
to play with here c5 and the position
becomes extremely
complicated and crazy but this is pretty
i think
pretty much a way to go here with with
black uh
let's say i should take g4 bishop e4 i
should have been one game like this it
was
prohaska versus and
in 2019 i believe in 2020 maybe half it
was 19
and
[Music]
in this game uh purple husker won
however uh
okay i'll show in a second would have
happened after queen c3
uh queen has to be the fan obviously
after hg4 uh so uh right now
black has white has some choice whether
um you know
to play um
i don't know take on c5 maybe take on b5
uh
i don't think on g4 right maybe two can
be fine it's not a good a but let's say
taking a c5 and taking g4 are two let's
say main moves
so uh let's see what happens after
d takes c5 if that this is in okay
actually let's say what happens after
root hd4 after root hg4 suddenly
black is lost sorry white is lost and
uh in the this will happen in the game
uh pro husker gavrilasko
and but here glasgow playing with bishop
takes a free which is a big mistake
and after it takes a free position
becomes extremely unclear
and both sides has his own chances and
eventually uh
prasca won how oops
didn't mean to clear that again however
in this position after rook hg4
rook takes f3 black blackwood have
played and after he takes the three
stakes d4
white is totally lost while he's totally
lost there is
such a huge powerful center uh
bishop will retreat queens under
attackers to retreat bush will retreat
to f5 the next move
rogue will have to retreat uh blacking
is say what king is in the center
black is simply totally winning uh
totally totally winning
um that's why root hd4 will be was a
huge mistake in this game
um however dtx5 was probably better
and bishop takes a free
has to be probably played and the game
the game the position is
totally insane what can i say it's in
the same position and again
such in even though black holes probably
of the best moves i analyzed i
analyzed it pretty deeply i don't want
to go into detail here but as
pretty deeply and everywhere pretty much
black i think
holds i could have missed something i'm
not saying but um
but in general black holes but pollution
is with such
tiny room for error margin for error
that
uh without prior preparation the plate
definitions with black
is extremely extremely dangerous and
this is where the
you know preparation uh with the modern
engines comes into play
uh that's why uh all the top players are
very strong as
you know and very like friends like
duboff who is very creative and
has lots of let's say ideas uh
you know that's why um you know i mean
that's how they work that's
that's how the world that's how they
search uh
also with myself in my own preparation
look for ideas
basically create those practical
problems to the opponent because
finding you know reason in such position
is extremely difficult rather than the
same
let's say some petrov or berlin right
in this position there is lots of going
on and there is very very fighting
position if you are
if uh prior preparation you can catch
even
gramos like like the dingley run here
because what the english did
he played after age 497 he immediately
made a mistake
after h5 h6 uh
suddenly position just lost g4
again we just go for the same strategy
same same idea of g4
and the position is just suddenly not
defendable for
for black if you if white black just
plays some let's say we should be seven
or something
the g5 follows obviously hd5 and right
now even
h6 will be considered bishop hd5 can be
considered knight hd5 can be considered
everything is you know i'll just put it
on the board which h5 is interesting
h6 looks very tempting as well knight g5
is possible as well
uh they're it's difficult to
i mean difficult to play here with with
um with black
um possibly this position just nearly
nearly lost
uh however uh one more i just will just
record one thing
here uh i wanted to show uh
let me just show my because my analysis
back
uh yeah okay okay 97 h5 uh h6 and
g4 right so uh
he took right now the ingredients played
into hg4
but right now uh there are certain
issues because that's only it takes be
five and the c takes b5 uh will run into
knight h2
uh or is even knight g5 and there are
some certain issues on this diagonal
after this let's say knight g5 is
interesting also knight h2 is possible
quite simply with material there's no
way around it wide with material and
move number what's
15. uh so this means
this shows what kind of you know what
kind of importance
preparation has on grandmaster level
um and also
where those grandmasters don't grow
masters search uh
for ideas and look for ideas because
it's easy to let's say surgeon let's say
some berlin or something you get some
equal position which is playable but
also maybe we can get equal position
with something which is something like
this
in which position is much harder to play
of course something like this
there are than berlin for instance uh so
um yeah so in the gameplan
and right now knight h2 again suddenly
uh
the game is just over out of nowhere the
game is just over it kind of rhymes but
the game is just pretty much over
because b takes c6 is a threat knight
hd4 is a threat
you cannot defend from both uh knight x
have two following the game because if
okay knight takes h2 then
we just play to be take c6 we should
take 6 takes
knight g4 and we can just win the
exchange
followed by rook g1 and yeah the game is
just over on g4 is hang on a5 is hanging
okay no g4 not yet because queen h1 mate
but okay at some point we'll be hanging
on g4 ruger 5 is
still a threat while it's totally
winning was just extra exchange while
it's totally winning here
all right so in the game followed knight
takes f2 which is pretty much
desperation here
king takes f2 queen h for check just
king of one
queen f6 just bishop f3 and uh
yeah hearing simply uh
resigned and very
interesting and very instructive stuff
from let's say theoretical perspective
but also
not only from theoretical perspective
but also from let's say psychological
perspective how to
let's say approach or point preparation
to catch psychologically upon in the
position
that he or she may not like and
here very nice preparation here by
daniel dubov
who just nicely
outplayed i mean let's just crush his
opponent because um
the ingredient presumably did not know
or did not remember how to
correctly react here uh one more thing i
wanted to show about this
line bishop b7 uh how dangerous is even
here
after h5 h6 g4 g4 rook g1 right
so uh this in this position uh let's say
if black doesn't want to play for f5
let's say black wants to play move like
king h8 king aj with the idea of you
know trying to get out of this h file
and try to in sorry g file and uh you
know try to make
king save without you know we can use
pawn structure here we move f5 without
this move
so right now i think what has very
strong attack after 95
and the point is that united's e5
detects e5
you know these pieces are not easily
coming to the game
uh i will develop some there it's simply
dangerous to play this position with
uh with black i can uh i can double on
the g5 maybe somehow maybe it'll get
through g3 or something like this
maybe i can you know bring my queen
let's say to the king side as well
ideas of queensland h6 are always in the
air or bishop g6 immediately
bishops bishop like h6 immediately i
mean um
all of it is there it's very very
dangerous position to play
if qh4 trying to you know maybe look for
counter play
or uh you know at least
activate the queen uh knight hg4 queen
takes g4 and right now
white has huge probably just winning
position uh
huge advantage or at least at least or
probably just the winning position after
move rook a3
which is a very very nice and elegant
move uh
rook comes to the play from the third
rank to g3 and
the game is just uh suddenly nearly
nearly decided
because with such attack uh against
black king there is nothing
i don't think that there is nothing
black black can do here
so uh yeah this is uh very interesting
uh
stuff very interesting uh preparation
and and in general line in catalan
for white and uh personally i i may
study it more myself because
it's definitely such a game it is
inspirational
um all right so this is the first thing
i want to discuss
a short one and but i just want to give
general a picture of the theory here
um you know how developed uh how
developed how the psychological
psychology works and
[Music]
i think this was a very interesting game
and next game i want to talk about
is game also versus being liran but this
time with white played maxine
vashelagraf
and in this game
followed in this game i mean uh vascular
graph maximization
played with white against his own
opening which is
which is sicilian um
in the game of e4 c5 by the way uh
ning given i played myself against
england he played against me
e5 e4 e5 here
i guess he decided to widen his
uh opening repertoire and began playing
cecilia nadev as well
which is not super surprising because i
know that he played also karaka in the
past he played uh
some time of sizzling taimanov as well
uh
so you know in every grand master
every grandmaster tries to you know look
for new openings and you look for new
uh positions to play searching new ideas
and so on
sometimes backfires like in this time uh
backfire against maybe you know the
lyran uh however you know
uh there's a general trend people
need to play pretty much or be ready at
least to play every position
which means the star has to be pretty
much universal
so okay come back to the game e4 c5
knight of three d6
d4 takes takes knight f6 knight c3 a6
so uh right now uh of course
night of the millions and
like you know possibilities for white
here um
lots of ideas for you know with both
i mean like more position of
both styles like more positional and
more aggressive um
[Music]
for instance one of the heaviest
analyzed
having the the most heaviest uh or like
the most analyzed lines here
is bishop e3 and bishop g5 those two are
i think the by far the most also h3 is
very interesting
all of them are uh you know playable
also bishop d3 will recently gain some
popularity which i myself employed some
of my games
uh there are also moves like a3 which
minus carson player in this tournament
um f4 there is f3 there's bishop c4
which
uh level iron tried against dink lyran
as well i think
uh lots of possibilities for
for white however uh
mvl decided to play move rook g1 which
is
somewhat rare but recently also
in here the the theory developed quite
substantially um
i think one of the you know pioneers of
this line let's say modern modern times
let's say over the last let's say a
couple of
maybe a year or two uh was yanni
pomenashi who played several times
and i and yeah and the idea of ruiji
wants to play move
g4 and g5 of course this i'm not saying
he's not the pioneer it's like the
smooth existence say
you know many many years ago already but
he kind of like revived it i think
because i don't recall it being so
popular before votes before his games
anyway rook g1 idea is to play g4 g5
and basically uh it is very similar to
line with h3 after the thing is that
after h3 uh
we are wasting sort of a tempo for you
know to play g4 and then g5 and h4 right
so we play
h3 first then play h4 so idea of g1 is
not to
waste time for his h3o and then play and
g4 g5 then h4 h5
very immediately have regular g1 which
is usually useful
and to create you know some attack on
the on the king side
so uh rg1 has was played
and here i always thought maybe some
probably
theory changed or something or some new
stuff but i think the safest in general
no matter what the theory suggests i
think is to e5 knight b3 and move like
bishop b6
4 by d5 in general black should
be okay here however i will not
guarantee that this is
equalizing 100 for sure what still has
some ideas there as well
uh the point is uh but in general what
the main idea here from bus
perspective if black can get to d5 and
make this kind of like
freeing uh breakthrough in the center uh
white will not be able to you know cause
too much threat say even such end games
after takes takes knight takes default
queen to hd5
are very close to equality maybe what is
slightly better in those english but
they are very very close to equality
the point is that if we do not play
knight d5 let's say we play in bishop v7
g5 97 this becomes kind of annoying for
to play with
with black because white immediately
gains some space on the queen side
sorry king side uh didn't waste time for
move h3 here which is extremely
big achievement and then also waste time
to play f3
so y can play move f4 for instance here
in this position or maybe play prepare
with bishop e3 and then queen
two or something like that and then f4
again many possibilities for white and
in general something that is black
should avoid
that's why i personally think d5 is
something the simplest
uh or maybe even slightly worse here for
black
in this endgame it should be definitely
horrible
um however is the not the most
entertaining
way to play you know neither right
because you know usually you people play
neither in order to look for initiative
counter at counter attack and so on
rather than just defending study world
end game right that's why
uh dingle iran played sort of in the
spirit of nidorf he played with b5
and he doesn't sort of like run away
from uh
you know fight and he sort of like
embraces it
so b5 and now a4 i think this is all
theory
uh b4 and now knight d5 and i think
there was some game uh
grin geary i'm not exactly sure
how this game
followed and not exactly sure this game
followed
uh however uh oh uh
okay in this game well e6 actually uh
knight takes f6 queen x6 and bishop e3
so this is you know some
this is possible to play with black
however
i think somehow that in this position
white should be somewhat
[Music]
better again
this point before it's a little bit over
extended maybe i can try to attack it
somehow in probably maybe a5
and uh if a5 is provoked let's say on
some maybe queen
or bishop b7 let's say queen d2 if a5
let's say i can play with bishop b5 or
something like this
uh of course bishop is not the best move
uh there will say better moves like uh
after let's say bishop b7 but again uh
maybe f3 you know there are some several
let's say or maybe bishop d3 even
there are a bunch of possibilities for
both sides here and
in general i believe that white should
be somewhat better
however this question is still playable
instead
[Music]
dingli ren decided to go for something
else he played knight takes e4
which is a very very um
risky move it is definitely the critical
move but it's also very risky why is
risky
it is risky because it simply
makes another move with the same piece
in the opening
white pieces already better developed
white uh
i mean black grabs upon and the center
upon true
but still grabs the pawn and runs into
some attack with
uh with for with this knight and the
white can definitely
put some uh pressure uh you know against
black king which is still in the center
so i was thinking about alternatives
towards move like e6 and knight x e4 and
i was thinking about move knight takes
d5
which is uh maybe not the most let's say
um
aggressive option but was also not
leading to scam come like boring
position
after it takes d5 to play move g6 and
the idea is to play bishop g7 short
castle
and i don't know there have been no
games like this so far uh perhaps there
could be some development in the future
here
uh but i i have to say i kind of like it
for for black especially this rook on g1
is a little bit misplaced like we play
ruiji want to play g4 g5 and hit them
from f6 right however
here and the rogue on g1 it doesn't
break pretty much actually we better
have look on h1 to support h4 h5 instead
right uh if this was here we'll play h4
h5 to
transport g6 and the king side with
ruben g1
something like this is not as strong
this possibly is another let's say
future development is opening
um let's say after b3 bishop g7 bishop
b2 i was analyzing something like this
not too much just briefly
but i didn't find any significant let's
say issues here for black
in some something like this still
white has some initiative and definitely
white can try moves like g4
and still push it's quite dangerous for
uh for black
and uh perhaps uh you know
this you know perhaps white but you look
here for some ideas
but you know it's less risky i think
still
than playing uh you know what uh dingley
ram play in the game even though
it probably holds according to my
analysis
um so
and yes you have to be treated with d5
and this knight f5 and just go for some
crazy
uh you know attacks but it's not so
clear because i make sometimes escape
towards the end game with move queen c3
at some length let's say e6 uh maybe i
can consider playing you know queen
takes if quincy free
uh and trading queens at some point and
trying to bail out with some you know
uh unclear end game uh
it is uh possible
so anyway here after
um
yeah so this was another xd5 so i would
like to talk about move knight takes e4
if knight xe4
you know this as i said this is
extremely risky for black
extremely risky but it is
the most critical as well right now i
think i'm i'm
pretty much certain that this was all
preparation here by mvl
uh bishop c4 and the idea is
we want to play queen e2 to change the
knight with the queen and quickly put
some pressure on the e file as well
so in the game for e6 and queen e2 of
course right now it takes d5 is out of
question
because simply bishop takes d5 wins the
knight
and after a move like
knight c5 which is the most let's say
logical after move like uh
knight f6 what has to be considered is
like bishop g5 obviously
it's looking kind of dangerous uh
to uh to black
so 95 makes sense not to go under such
pin but right now
uh there isn't strong move by nvl c3
so again uh white needs to very quickly
develop some initiative
in order to prove conversation for the
pawn and the
c3 is does it very very well because
right now uh
you know i just want to play stick
before and keep this knight from c5
and you cannot
you i'm not giving black time to
comfortably consolidate the position and
complete the development
because uh if bishop b7 is what happened
in the game i still can simply take only
seven
uh not a quintet seven and stakes before
and i win the pawn back and i got a pair
of bishops
and the wise push is simply better
and this is this is simply unpleasant
position for for black already
and this is again an example in a little
bit different opening of course than the
previous one
of how to look for ideas
and we are basically i think coding
lyran here in this opening
and he managed to
put some practical problems especially
you know in the rapid game
uh his devotions are very
very very difficult to solve
after moves like c3 uh you know it's
difficult to such
to you know what prior preparation go
play b take c3 and allow move b4
which is after which we the knight from
c5 is
anyway uh chased away and uh
it is not clear where this knight should
go because knight d7 allows
all kind of like knight e6 possibilities
and so on
uh and knight b7 looks simply totally
awful
and ugly like knight b7 looks really
ugly
is awful here and so from practical
point of view
from human perspective it is a very
difficult position to play
still i'd like to share my discoveries
here and
after before the thing is that if knight
cd7
which is again the more human move i
think what's on the verge of winning
move before g5
uh even knight f6 we could
i was talking about the queen to fight
the moment after i have six why can't
even long castle we just i found i
thought when i was looking at this
i was like really really uh impressed by
all those
let's say files those lines because
but it makes sense right because uh
white
has huge advantage in development huge
all pieces are playing
black has two extra pawns but king is
still at center
and the and
you know didn't complete any
only only only that former six is
playing right so it makes sense that
white should go for total attack all
all the way you know attack with
everything and
quickly of all the pieces and even go
for long castle we're assuming the king
shouldn't be safe
but in reality it doesn't matter because
black has no pieces to attack him in
this king
with because you know the king on c1 is
um i mean qs1 is pretty safe because
black doesn't have any pieces to attack
it with
all of them are on the back rank so here
i think black has more
um white has i mean more than sufficient
conversation for the material
and presumably even you know nearly
nearly winning winning chances
uh so after b4 my conclusion was the
knight
b7 was the only move here that you know
kept the balance
but knight b7 you can just imagine i
think how difficult
difficult such move here is uh well i
forgot to mention after 1997 bishop
g5 if queen g5 there could be
considerable lightness c7 that's the
problem because if king d8
we simply win the queen and if
king e7 sorry if king is seven
we can at least take the rook on e8 at
least take the organization
always that are extremely dangerous as
well
uh so uh but at least we can take the
rook on i8
so uh this is also you know very
dangerous so
knight b7 even ib7
has to be played and uh right now i
analyze several
analysts two options either b5 or bishop
b5
and in both instances position is
extremely crazy
and as i say black is very likely okay
but uh to prove it over the board and
without pride preparation
is extremely extremely difficult for
instance after bishop b5
uh it takes b5 queen uh i mean sir
bishop g5
queen g5 queen takes b5 and
you know here i think black white has at
least a draw
uh with qb6 you know and queen d5
uh with queen e8 of course there is
knight c7 but
here probably the game will just end
with a draw
because yeah there is no no not much
burden than this
uh but you know going for something like
this with black without
preparation and allow here who's such
uh to be honest q7 doesn't work because
this is knight d8
and suddenly black somehow holds
everything but
uh you know as soon as 7
and you know black holes and
in indian black winds but you know uh
to figure out everything like this over
the board in such a crazy position
and unlikely is unlikely something like
this will
ever ever happen um
considering how complex this position is
so um
bishop b5 and after bishop b5 uh there's
8xb5 which leads
please subscribe bishop d7 which also
leads to some unclear
position after we should be sent king
takes d7
uh you know take who will take hero
queen king seven without pride
preparation
after move that queen g4 h5 queen h3
plays bass the best move absolutely move
absolutely the best move
g5 which is again extremely difficult to
play such move
the more let's say commas would be to
play on a play move like king yed or
something like this and then
uh you know uh try to consolidate
position but this is
way way too uh to pass it let's say i
can play planets e6
and after this you know i have moved
like bishop g5 suddenly white is
all the way you know attacking and
pretty much why you should be winning
here
while uh you know move like g5 is
totally com
computer rescue right it is not uh
it's not easy to play such movies
especially in the rapid game
but yeah this simply works for black
suddenly and
according to my analysis after you know
bishop hd5 queen g5 and ib6
uh king g8 queen takes c3
black somehow uh holds here even rook a7
or even one white wants to because there
is such possibility to repeat the
position
but also black can try to play for a
move like bishop g7 anyway position is
totally insane and
going too much into the it doesn't make
much sense i just wanted to illustrate
what kind of you know crazy positions
black has to consider and how much room
for error is in such positions for black
here
especially if white knows exactly what
to do and black doesn't um
yeah but you know first of all knight b7
is extremely extremely difficult move to
play
that's why uh i think it was a great try
by mvl
from practical perspective to go for
something like this and here
he induced immediate mistake by uh doing
the right he played with bishop e7
after 1967 queen 287 mistakes before
suddenly
uh position is extremely dangerous to
black
white got the pawn back has pair of
bishops
and
[Music]
as their development as well as better
pieces
after you know knight d7 uh
manville played bishop d2 and the idea
right now for white is to play with long
castle
bishop c3 and begin attacking on the
kings of g4 uh
g5 and so on and uh with such
if white king goes towards the king side
sorry the queen side
the white king will be saved there
because there are three pawns
guarding it all sorts of pieces
especially bishop on c3 will be very
powerful
and the white sorry black pieces are not
developed
as well as as as good as well as
white pieces are and in the game uh why
is it slightly much better i don't think
black
white is winning but white is much
better and in the game being lyran uh
played all the natural moves and lost in
2024 moves only
we should be free okay shortcut is
logical long castle b96
very logical again knight c2 uh it was a
very nice move actually by
mvl he doesn't trade the knights
why he doesn't trade because he has
better pieces and those nights
black knights are sort of hanging uh
like
it will be easier for black to play if
those knights are traded
uh but uh the iphone e5 will run into
some attack
and it makes no sense to trade the you
know knights knight xc6 because
first of all 94 is remains a threat but
can play with e5 bishop b6
suddenly position becomes uh more and
more unclear
uh if we play knight c2 well this knight
only five we have to go for
go from there somewhere and because f4
was probably loom
probably looms uh and the f4 root b8 bc3
and knight g6 and simply g3 covering you
know f4 square
and the position suddenly gets worse and
worse from move to move
i would like to note how black basically
black's initiative on the king sorry
queenside is stuck this
pawn before is very well guarded by the
knight in bishop
blackhand opened the queenside anyway uh
f5 will be always meant by b5 for
instance
and black has very easy plan of playing
h4 h5
uh maybe f4 as well and just
go for the attack on the king side and
there is not there
there is very little that black can do
about it and the game ended five moves
which is insane but uh there was nothing
to do after
five more moves e5 very logical move
again try to play bishop e6
bishop d5 uh queen d7 perhaps 98 could
have been played here and
followed by maybe bishop e6 but it's
hard to criticize
queensland because 97 also comes with
the same idea
but f4 right now is
the problem right now again if ft it
takes f4
she takes the f4 it only helps y to
basically open this
rook on the g file so the sixth move rg1
finally became useful
to you know to bring this rook to this g
file and continue the attack here
um or the develop the attack here so
white black shouldn't be taking but uh
so that therefore didn't really play
bishop b7
but now simply we should be free back we
do not want to trade because even by for
the cost of the pawn if black
let's say after kimby one or something
played well
black would have played knight d4 there
will be some you know
relief here uh even there is no even
forecast of the pawn because just you
know
uh knight xd4 should have simply okay
for black
uh but again we do not want to trade
here with with white
that's why we should be free uh in the
game just it takes the phone which is
pretty much desperation
he should have done something else uh
i'm not exactly sure what because potion
is horrible either way
but after this is only uh you know
uh speeds up the process here because
after queen f5 queen d2
the ingredient simply resigned
and i would like to know i would like to
know one thing here
the position in the which he resigned is
equal in material
but positionally it was extremely
difficult to play with black
and the game just ended very very
abruptly
after you know a few few moves here and
which were also natural moves
but you know it's just the difficult
version was
was too big to basically hand to to
handle uh
in the in the game um against such
player like mvl so this is how the game
ended
and again this was a very nice example
of preparation of grand master
preparation
by mvl who
nicely won this game the last game i
want to talk about i don't think we have
time but i'll just quickly show one
moment from this game
which is game of manus carson versus
daniel dubov and this is the game in
this moment with the position in this
moment
uh the game also and in 25 moves that's
why i wanted to bring it
you know along with the topic however
it's not
to that extent because there was no like
kind of like huge uh
you know opening idea that you know um
dubois employed in this game uh but um
you know anyway he won against mars in
25 moves with black pieces which is
uh which is definitely something of
course
mine was made a huge mistake in this
position because he played with bishop
d2
and this move is simply nearly losing if
i can put it like that
because after with d2 bishop g4 the game
is just nearly over
instead uh and i i looked at the game
live
and the chess bomb was suggesting
another later check with my own engine
that f3 basically kills the entire
attack from back and white has
very nice positional advantage and the
you know the
the game is just the game should be over
maybe not over
soon but definitely white is not taking
any significant uh
risk here probably that one of the lines
here is that this this
bishop g4 perhaps is met by blue g3 at
least maybe there is something else as
well
but at least this is fine for black it's
for white i mean
also if y wants to be super safe because
if i remember correctly
also a draw was already insufficient for
magnus to win the
the match he could have taken
it detects e4 and the game would be
just you know very
clean list tiering towards you know
equal towards equality
uh miles played bishop d2 and this was a
huge mistake because after after bishop
g4
uh suddenly he cannot play a three
okay he did play a free because he saw
had to uh because
if he doesn't do it he's gonna get
things of himself checkmate on the light
square with such powerful bishop here
on this whole squares i can play you
know queen um g4
queen h5 some of these go forward is
made and the game is just over
so he had to play a three battle should
take the three
queen f2 you know rook g4 and anyway
this
position of his king is totally
compromised and
there is pretty much nothing he could do
um
so arugi one rook f6 detects e4
uh yeah queen h5 continuing the attack
rook e3 mission takes e4 there there's
pretty much nothing he could do here we
need rook into and now final
uh tactical blow root hg3 because after
hd
here mine was resigned because after
rook to hg3 queen takes e2
uh wins the game with the queen and
after hd g3 there is a checkmate of
queen h1
uh yeah so this is uh all
i mean and i know that last game i spent
like maybe a few minutes only on this
um on this on the last one however i
think that
all of them were extremely interesting
and lots of life
and um especially the first two they
involves two there were lots of
um interesting uh um
positions uh that could have arise and
like apart from the game
uh you know the lines that uh we
discussed
uh were you know perfect and crazy
and uh unique and and you know this is
how pretty much grandmaster
preparation works we look for ideas
where we
can trick our opponent or like um even
if the person is equal objectively we
can
uh we hope that it will be not be easy
to play for our opponent
and that's why we can look for points
you know to win win the games in the
future and win some points and
and so on uh so okay this will be it
for from me for today i hope you guys
enjoyed
my analysis and and the games and
i will see you next time thank you have
a good night